one good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Wednesday also
known as hump day so don't forget to uh
gyrate to get get a little damaged my
brethren should be here to celebrate
they should be here
standing with your arm around me here
what song is that you should be here I
don't know it's a weird song No it's
like like giving like a fake like Disney
Channel energy what song is that I have
to I have to look at it you should be
here I have to look it up I'm sorry
because this is an itch I need to
scratch it it's like I don't even know
if it's sung by a boy or a girl
oh it's Taylor Swift no yeah no no no
it's Cole Swindell oh yeah oh my God not
me thinking it was Taylor Swift that's
like she's so much better than that she
would never she would never you should
be yeah yeah yeah what a random like by
the way speaking of Music speaking of
music good music yesterday Jack and I
dropped an amazing patreon episode it is
a over an hour long it's an hour and 10
Minute Podcast part podcast part radio
so we do this segment we did it a while
ago and we brought it back yesterday
because there's so much music coming out
that we've been really enjoying called
toast radio where it's basically like
you're listening to a radio show on the
radio but it's actually good it's two of
your favorite gals laughing chatting
talking about music but also just
talking about like life celebrities and
then we're introducing some of our
favorite music from the last maybe two
months so it's ten songs five of them
were chosen by me five of them were
chosen by Jackie they're cross genre
um and then we chat in between each song
for a couple of minutes about the song
about you know making it about ourselves
whatever it may be so it's about like 40
minutes of chatting 30 minutes of music
and it's so good the feedback has been
so good people love it it's really great
if you commute or if you are taking a
long walk and you want to listen to
music we also want to listen to your
favorite girls yeah when I was getting
ready this morning I had to hit up toast
radio and people said like while they
were cleaning it's just like such a fun
idea concept and we had so much fun
doing it and the songs are fire flames
and I hope that we introduce you to
something that you haven't heard yet
yeah so it was um very exciting that's
what was going on yesterday with us
and yeah it's Wednesday I went out to
dinner last night it was delicious
what'd you eat I had a salmon
and a little Margarita Pizza Yum I love
a pizza like as an appetizer for the
table you know of course you know just
like is that a hot tea no no but I just
feel like it's not spoken about nearly
enough as it should be
yes because we don't talk about it
because it's just so obvious but like I
don't know I feel like it's not obvious
like we didn't order it and then I was
like wait should what if we just got a
pizza and everyone's like let's get a
pizza oh so you're saying if you weren't
there it's not something that like other
people would have done I'm basically
just trying to say like had I not been
invited to the dinner it wouldn't have
been the same it would have been a pizza
list dinner it would have been a pizza
list dinner so that's what I did Ben is
home so I was able to sleep it was great
that is great I had a succession last
night oh you did I did and um it was as
you said what was the thing you were
about to say that I was like no
uh spoiler alerts spoiler alert shiv
being pregnant right does that change
things much a little bit I think like if
you know these guys were gonna push her
out and now they know she's pregnant
like they're gonna push her out even
more oh right oh like these business
honchos all men yeah I guess that's like
corporate things and now she like
certainly doesn't want to tell anyone
because she's already being pushed out
got it okay and then of course Tom
Tom is the father I assume like I assume
yeah I mean they were trying right they
were talking about it yeah
I don't know but we know that chip is
pregnant in real life so it's cool that
they're doing it yes and I hope that she
didn't take that tumble you know I hope
that was a stunt double because she is
pregnant in real life and that was a
horrible oh my God I literally gasped I
do love though like ran like shows when
they randomly throw in somebody falling
I know I was actually gonna text you
when she fell I was did I relate to it
is that what you were gonna ask it's
just like falling is kind of your thing
yeah obviously succession is inspired by
my life um and I love to see you know
women out here falling not pregnant
women not pregnant women no it was only
two steps so yeah I think it was more so
just like embarrassing humiliated for
someone who is embarrassado yes finally
a correct use of the term and embarrass
had a woman feeling embarrassado
wow we've kind of come full circle as a
brand I feel like all of our episodes of
the toast have brought us to just that
moment it was kind of like what we just
experienced is a similar feeling to what
I experienced when we finally had Sarah
and Aaron Foster on
to discuss Justice for David Foster it
was like a full circle completion of
some sort of R like that's why we do
what we do so you can get to say
embarrassado and embarrassado in the
same sentence using dual meanings using
dual meanings that's beautiful so other
than that I liked your explanation of
the episode better than the episode so I
should just keep going with turdies
explainers but it was cute and then I
guess like at the end Kendall is like
activated right right with his Grinch
smile spreading across his face when he
wants to you know publicly slander his
father yeah posthumously posthumously
without anyone knowing us in a soft way
I am obsessed with the word posthumously
okay
um I think because for a long time I
spelled it wrong because like in my head
it's Post humorously Yeah so and now
that I know it correctly sometimes and
you really can't use it that much
because it has to be posthumously when
you use it correctly like it just I feel
like I've once like I should win some
sort of prize you know yeah posthumously
well don't go using it too much hope not
sporadically
not sporadically of course the
references are just on fire today I
don't want to jinx it I know that's like
three really good ones posthumously in
America and not sporadically of course
no what is she saying and that's
sporadically I'll be seeing you
know I hope not sporadically I hope not
sporadically yes that's my boyfriend
Paul Rudd
gymnastics teacher to the Stars to the
stars that was you I know that you have
a whole new set of makeup
um because you have like a set here in
New York you're looking stunning really
yeah and there was a lot of comments
about like your makeup like giving Glam
well yeah I got some new things but like
of my things that I use there were a few
things that I couldn't get like you gave
me the setting powder that I'm loving
because there is a run on Laura Mercier
trailer powder it is
out of stock everywhere like online I
was doing like Sephora instacart and I
tried one more place oh I sent Zach oh
Bloomingdale's great and he it's nowhere
so Claudia generously gave me like uh
Givenchy Libre it's so good right it's
so good like I'm gonna buy it and
actually it's probably better for you
than it is for me because it has pinky
undertones yeah oh I'm so glad you're
liking it keep it I will but there's not
that much left dirty it's half full
Jackie it's helpful
uh I'm gonna get it you should I really
liked it oh good yeah because
um I'm going viral on Tick Tock what are
you doing there this is the thing like I
spend hours and weeks and then like I
put up some crap and I probably I
probably took 14 seconds to record it
and put it up over a million views what
is it some dumb like I have to watch
yeah it has the support from someone was
like somebody made a thing and it was
like guess a celebrity just based on
their mouth and like who better than me
could do that I got every single one and
it wasn't even hard but people are like
this is so impressive I'm like it is you
should listen to the toes all right do
you know what I do for a living okay
Jackie's watching my Tick Tock kisses
let's see if you can guess it turn the
volume all the way down okay
it hasn't started yet right no there's
oh okay did you get it no I didn't know
turn the volume down so you don't spoil
it for yourself
oh wow no yeah I don't know any of them
no
yeah late in me sorry I would have
guessed that too but yeah but you did
yeah but you did it
Emily oh no I wouldn't have gotten that
I wouldn't got that either no
it's so quick Jimmy Kimmel yeah yeah no
Fallon
no that's okay but you know what I meant
yeah
Meryl Streep yeah the Meryl Streep on
was easy they showed like her whole face
yeah it was like not even hard okay this
is the last one uh Jennifer Aniston oh
yeah sorry no there's one more that was
really hard that I almost did it get
away let's see if I can get it
man Sam Hunt
you know what I thought it was Sam Hunt
too at first how did you get that's
crazy I know by the way I didn't think
it was so crazy but I guess that's like
a skill that I have guessing celebrities
just based on their mouths and you
should that's what all the comments were
about go on tour I'm guessing now you
know they play that game on Watch What
Happens Live a lot like whose nose is it
yeah and I guess I'm like really good at
it because I get it there too I I
thought it was like not a difficult
concept
and that's why it went viral people were
like so impressed I'm like wait do I
have a talent
yes I am going viral like Dreams made of
oh and I'm going to a Broadway show
tonight which show I've been wanting to
see it for so long have you heard about
it it's called n Juliet
maybe it is the work of iconic pop
producer Max Martin
so it's all Max Martin music and like he
stems from like current to like Celine
Dion like a lot of really impressive
music but the concept of the show is um
what would have happened if Romeo and
Juliet like didn't die so it's like the
aftermath of Romeo needs to see that
Zach from Love is Blind why Romeo and
Juliet didn't work out for a reason did
he say that over and over again when
like bliss's family didn't like him like
the way I was so turned off by him like
I actually physically had to tune out
what he was saying also I sent you this
on Instagram last night yeah um I just
hacked I just feel like I want to say
that I was right you know when we were
and people thought our love is blind
recap was like so radical they're like
not you guys like disagree with
everything that the internet is saying
it was like oh can we watch a show no
not only about this show the internet is
always right so I want to agree with
them all the time so what he had said
was like I mean you came on the show to
be famous and I was like that's weird
because he then proceeded to plug his
own Instagram it seems like Zach was the
one who came on the show to be famous
then somebody thank you I don't follow
him but a bunch of people send this to
me yesterday like turdy you were right
he got Paparazzi in the airport which
maybe he called maybe he didn't he TMZ
video Papa TMZ video Paparazzi so maybe
he called maybe he didn't I feel like he
did but what he proceeded to do was then
like download the video from TMZ
uploaded to it is his Instagram story in
full and tag like TMZ tag the
photographer tag everyone the link to
the article like that's what a person
who wants Fame would do I would do it
because I want fame and I don't shame
other people who do so just further
proof now that I was right Irina
honestly I haven't even seen a thing
about Irina she hasn't been thirsty at
all her Instagram hasn't even come
across my desk like not since her
apology right which was truly painful to
watch
yeah so once again charity was right
which actually not once again that never
happens no but you've got to savor the
moment so you're two for two today plus
the lips
two for two today plus the lips so yeah
I'm going viral and Tick Tock I was
right about Zach from Love's blind
everything's coming up today everything
said you love to see it you do you are
wearing one of our new merch sweatshirts
you look fabulous oh thank you yes I am
wearing the pink crew neck that says the
toes that Claude wore yesterday in a
size large merch launches tomorrow hide
your kids hide your wife 10 a.m Eastern
Time toastmarch.com new crewnecks
accessories like mugs and phone cases
all of the products that we will be
launching will be on our Instagram so
you can you know learn more nearby yeah
learn before you buy
learn before you shop shop before you
learn learn and shop shop and learn
um so that's toastmirch.com we've got a
great show it's Wednesday which means we
have your toasters we can help some
girlies in need I think it's been
forever since we did your toaster well I
did it last week with
who was on Wednesday Margo yeah and um
the snatchers episode of the toast it's
just so interesting you know you think
you know your audience the Saturn's
episode of the toast outperformed all of
these big fancy guests is that crazy
she's just a snatchler I don't even want
to tell her that because like now she'll
be like Oh I'm too good oh oh you want
me to come on the toast what are you
going to do what are you gonna do for me
yeah
so I love that for her though everyone
needs a little counseling from the
counselor so true dear counselor snitch
dear future counselor oh Meghan Trainor
had a baby did you see that no I didn't
yeah she posted on Tick Tock I saw that
she said that her husband had been
shaving her legs and I think it was
implied like her hoo-ha yeah of course
while her bump was too big of course and
she's also writing a book dear future
mama oh that's cute yeah what is it in a
memoir I don't know but I saw the cover
and her kid is on it her kid is really
cute he has red hair does it look like
Memoir Vibes yeah cause like her and her
kid are on it you know Memoirs of a
Megan Memoirs of a trainer
[Laughter]
Memoirs of a streisas better I never saw
the movie Memoirs of a Geisha but like
the way the title of that film has
continued yeah continued to inspire so
many different facets of my life like I
should probably see it or maybe that
would ruin it it might or I think it
might be a really serious movie and then
you might feel weird about making light
of the title I might but if I don't feel
light making light of you know a
Sophie's Choice
but we do feel weird about it and we do
that's why we've changed it to a
deandra's choice yeah yeah but
it's just not the same no it's not the
same what choice did Deandra have after
all I feel actually like the Andrew
Simmons former Real Housewives of Dallas
really did have a lot of tough decisions
you know she had a lot going on like
between her mom you know her stepson he
was kind of troubled like there are a
lot of lots of choices being made
yeah sure should she defend Leanne
should she not you never know what
someone's going through and the choices
that they make I mean life's about
choices life's about choices and we
always say we do and you should make
them don't let them pass you by some
people don't want to make a choice no
it's hard one of my biggest pet peeves
is like people who don't like make
choices or just like indecisive but I
also am one of those people because I
understand that
mentality completely because like it's
so much responsibility to make a choice
yeah and it's always the wrong one I
disagree I think there's no wrong choice
the wrong choice is not making one
you know what I guess I think whichever
one you choose like if you follow that
path
it's right for you that's beautiful and
you'll Bloom where you're planted I know
I actually used that yesterday in like a
conversation who are you talking to it's
like giving advice not me not you who
are you giving you give advice to other
people that's so disgusting yeah yeah
you know when I'm called on who
I was talking to Zach
he's constantly like this is probably
like who are like I don't really talk
like that especially like you know you
know woven pillow language
exactly you just have to have to laugh
love right right breathe in but like
dead seriously I'm like Bloom where you
are planted yeah and he was like okay
sure whatever that means
the crazy wife Off Your Rocker again
it's just good advice it's good sound
advice I should Bloom where I'm planted
I feel like I recently used that phrase
I think we were doing maybe even at the
University of Miami yeah
because it was one of those phrases I
feel like this happens with people
Everyone is like drawn to a different
phrase sometimes you hear a phrase that
like either really accurately reflects
like where you're at in your life or you
just find yourself using it a lot and
it's like kind of becomes like your
phrase it's just like a good use of
language yeah there are a lot of I feel
like oh this was I think when Remy or
Margo was on the show she called me out
because like I was using a lot of
phrases I said like those in Glass
Houses the call is coming from inside
the house couldn't get arrested I was
like using a lot of like euphemism
Mystic phrases metaphors metaphors and
she was like why are you using so many
phrases I was like
okay rude I didn't realize that I was I
didn't realize I was under attack no but
sometimes like those phrases are the
only thing to say yeah instead of saying
you know like whatever Bloomer you're
planted translates to you're saying it
poorly or saying it in a phrase right
like maybe you should just try and like
grow like and say like a thousand in the
place that you're in right because the
place that you're not is like not the
place where you're meant to grow yeah or
I could just say Bloom where you're
planted or I could just say that and do
it that way you will so what a great
show I feel as though it's a great time
to dive in what do you think I think so
it's always a great time to dive in no
that's actually not true no we could
always wax poetic yeah and sometimes we
do yeah we do and I think that today we
shall continue to yeah so without
further do here are the past five
stories that you need to know oh before
we start I have a funny story to tell
you that has a lot to do waxing poetic
yeah that has a lot to do with what I'm
about to talk about so the craziest
thing just happened to Ben and I feel
like it's a cautionary tale and it's
also just a hilarious story so for
spritz they have all these different
reps in like different markets and they
have like credit cards to buy
promotional materials for you know going
into stores and selling Spirits so they
have like you know Flyers like a company
card a company card and so when they
were doing expensive expenses these reps
like never have more than like 200 on
their monthly accounts because they're
really just buying like flyers and
cardboard and stuff like that and this
one rep it was like this really cool
young guy that Ben knows I think in in
Texas his credit card charges were like
twelve hundred dollars so Ben called
them up and was like by the way why was
your expenses like it's fine but like
can you tell me what you spent all this
money on he was like those gift cards
that you asked me to get and Ben was
like what
he's like you literally texted me asking
me to get you gift cards and Ben's like
what are you talking about
so the guy sends his screenshots to Ben
and he's like as he's sending them he's
like okay in hindsight I realize like I
think we might have been scammed like
someone was impersonating you me and Ben
are cackling reading these messages
somebody impersonated Ben Jackie to a t
signed off on these text messages thank
you Ben zoffer founder and CEO of Spritz
like literally they had so much
information on Ben and they asked this
guy to pick up gift cards he's like hey
I'm coming to town for some clients can
you pick up gift cards so guy was like
yeah sure what do you need right and he
runs to like a a drugstore and buys all
these gift cards sends pictures and the
guys is being like I need them now I
need them now please get them now and
the guy who works around is like okay
sure just doing what is what his boss is
asking and signed off on every message
founder and CEO Spritz like if it was
crazy how much information this person
had when they were impersonating Ben
that's so scary it is it does make you
chuckle and that's like a low stakes
right situation but it's so scary and
there are so many crazy stories of
impersonation scams and so and Ben is
like um
like a tech savvy young person he's not
like who you would think is like
typically susceptible and so is this guy
they're not who you would think is
susceptible to impersonation scams and
that's why Amazon is really passionate
about making sure that you are as
protected as you possibly can be when
shopping so with Amazon it's so
important that you verify your purchases
on Amazon so if you receive a message
about the purchase of a product or a
service do not respond to that message
or click on the link in the message
always log into your Amazon account use
the Amazon mobile app and confirm that
it really is your purchase before taking
any action you can trust Amazon's app
and website they will not ask for
payment over the phone or by email only
on the mobile app on their website or in
one of their physical stores they will
never call to ask for payment I once got
a call from someone saying it was Amazon
I'm like Amazon does not call at first I
was like wait what because I had made
like a big purchase on Amazon weirdly
and that was just coincidence so I was
like oh they're calling me about my big
purchase yeah and then I like took a
pause and I was like they wouldn't call
me they've never called me before and
I'll check my app if there's an issue
they know where to reach me so it's so
important to be be wary of urgency and
that's really something I saw in Vince
the guy was like so panicked come on
hurry I need it now so if there's like
that sense of urgency that's like a
really big red flag for scammers because
they often try to create a sense of
urgency to persuade you to do what
they're asking do not be pressured to
buy a gift card gift card is like the
biggest red flag the Amazon will never
ask you to purchase a gift card no
legitimate sale or transaction will
require you to pay with gift cards you
can learn more about common gift card
scams on the Amazon Help pages so if
you're ever unsure just contact Amazon
you can also see what else has been
reported in a similar situation because
in the US Amazon has partnered with the
Better Business Bureau to provide
consumers a searchable scam tracker that
enables you to search suspicious
Communications reported by others via
email URL phone number and more so I
know everyone thinks they're like above
it like I'm smart I could never like I'm
not my grandma but you know what Ben and
his co-worker who are both like young
guys who work at a startup they're very
tech savvy they are the perfect example
of people who probably would never be
you know susceptible to something like
this and they got scammed and they
didn't even realize until a month later
no the scammers are adapting yeah and so
we have to too you have to to always be
on alert when you're shopping with
Amazon which I know a lot of you do
almost on a daily basis trust their app
trust their website do not trust term
phone calls turn emails out of the blue
always check the app be wary of urgency
be wary of anybody asking you to get a
gift card and always verify your
purchases on Amazon thank you Amazon
we're glad to partner with you today
because this is a very important PSA it
is thank you so much Claudia you're
welcome
like I was like roasting Ben but you
know what like it kind of freaked me out
like if it could happen to Ben yeah it
can happen to me yeah Ben has gotten
scammed like a couple times
both of you are pretty gullible though
no I don't think so that you're not
skeptical no I'm not I don't know I
could see you like me like oh my God I
got this text oh my God they want me to
go to like red card we go to the Oscars
that's how you can like actually scam me
if anybody if anybody was looking to
literally if anybody's looking to scammy
just invite me to the Oscars oh my God
don't please don't do it are you ready
for our first story I am I would say the
stories today are in no particular order
you know just sort of importance the
chip let the chips fall where they may
sort of thing
first viewers are panning Kelly rip and
Mark Consuelos his brutal first live
show together the eagerly anticipated
first episode of Live with Kelly and
Mark starring married couple Kelly Ripa
and Mar Consuelos has garnered mixed
reviews many viewers accused the married
couple of fake banter and being boring
during the hour-long show Ripa was even
accused of repeatedly interrupting him
when Mark shared the edible Queen when
Mark shared that the two had enjoyed a
romantic stroll through the park
recently
uh she had interrupted him on that story
I guess
um and there was some Pete some kissing
oh that's unnecessary so I haven't seen
it mostly because I don't care but I do
want to say as somebody who can speak
from experience like working with your
partner I think a lot of people would
think it's like seamless chemistry it's
probably more difficult than working
with like a co-worker so I'm going to
give Kelly like a little breathing room
to you know find their footing it took
me and been years actually years even
aside from it being her husband like a
new co-host it takes a second to find
your step like attorney and I we do a
little dance yeah it's like a little
salsa Tango yeah and it takes a while it
takes it takes time and being
interrupted is part of our dance yeah
it's one of the steps right it's
gorgeous amazing and maybe they'll work
that into theirs as well but it takes
time I don't think if you're if you've
been a lover of Kelly and Live with
Kelly that like you should never watch
again that's what people are saying this
is the last time I'm watching and it's
like give them a beat even regardless of
being husband and wife but that does add
another layer and it's like if she was
interrupting her co-host you'd just be
like oh Kelly's interrupting but then it
becomes a critique on their marriage yes
I know and it's just a lot and I'm gonna
stand with my girl Kelly and just be
like give her a second no I agree like
our whole perception of Kelly has like
really kind of at least for me like
shifted yeah because now I feel like
this extreme kinship with her as
somebody who like used to get absolutely
annihilated when they podcasted with
their husband and you're right it turns
into like a critique on your job which
is always tough to a critique on your
marriage which is so deeply personal
[__] all the way off so I stand with
Kelly as well she has my full support
she will get through this they will get
to a place to transition from like home
life to work life like publicly it's it
takes it takes a minute and you know
people are very unforgiving so I'm gonna
give her a break I'm gonna give her a
few weeks to figure it out yeah to me
this doesn't mean like the show is bad
or he was the wrong choice they just
need time and also it's not only like
Mark has to adjust to being a daytime
talk show host and I'm sure the times
that he went on before it was like fun
and all about him I feel like that's
exactly what happens with our husbands
like there's a difference between having
them on as a guest and it's like we're
just asking you questions about you
versus like okay now you are
co-captaining this year you're here to
work you're here to work so I'm sure
he's figuring that out but also like
Kelly has to
kind of re-jigger herself around whoever
her new
co-host is yeah no for sure I also just
think like these things take time
chemistry is a very you know Kelly
Clarkson said it best chemistry is very
she actually like didn't say great yeah
no I don't know like it could be good
and bad she said chemistry it could be
really good or really bad it was yeah I
just felt like there was a tighter way
to say it from such a Lyricist I know so
I wasn't sure like what I was trying to
say I'm just like
they'll figure it out chemistry man I'm
not worried about them no I'm not
worried either and I'm giving Kelly
Grace I'm giving Kelly Grace and then I
was looking for stories this morning and
my God page six was
riching they said Andy Cohen seems to
show support for Kelly Ripa and you know
because she's been dragged for her first
episode with Mark and I was like oh I
wonder what he said that's nice of him
and I go and it's like he posted an
Instagram story of a Snoopy cartoon and
it was like you'll be okay that
literally could have been about quite
literally anything that's crazy why
would they assume that that was about
Kelly there wasn't a shadow tag or a
small tag no
isn't that weird that is weird look I
get reaching for stories because like we
know today was like not like a crazy big
news day but my God like have some
Integrity that was crazy yeah
damn
are you ready for our next Story another
host who's getting some backlash oh yes
too yes fans are petitioning to remove
Nick and Vanessa Lachey as the Love is
Blind hosts
fans are calling for the couple's
removal from the Buzzy Netflix dating
show over claims the pair were biased
towards some of the cast of the season
for reunion some person wrote this ring
just feels so awkward doesn't seem like
there's any flow hosts are way too
biased it's just weird another one said
another in popular opinion but Nicki
Minaj are bad hosts who are clearly
biased so this is just like a Roundup of
Mean Tweets plus a petition that has
garnered more than six thousand
signatures which isn't a lot no it's not
um saying that they should be removed
but see the thing is is like I thought
they did a bad job too but it's almost
unfair because it was alive like I have
actually thought I remember last season
thinking that Vanessa really did a very
good job Nick was mute and I didn't even
understand why he was sitting there but
I thought Vanessa was really good and
it's it's clear that she's just like a
host who needs to be edited like oh I
didn't think it was the live aspect I
feel like she's doing the job that
they've asked her to do by injecting so
much of herself into it like I don't
think she's going off script so much I
feel like Netflix or the producers of
Love Is buying like like how invested
Nick and Vanessa are and they've chosen
to like have hosts who aren't just like
this third party objective yeah person
and more people who are like ingrained
in the show who are super fans of the
show and also like can give marriage
advice along the way I did agree that
she was biased yeah um but I feel like
if they wanted her to be unbiased they
would have said so yeah I feel like she
was given license and encouraged to
really like to take to almost like
represent the internet yes in her job
that's what she did that's exactly what
it is so who do people feel like she was
rude to appall she sent him flowers she
did yeah he posted it on his Instagram
story and Paul was also TMZ at the
airport
um
do you think she sent him flowers
because she like felt bad about this I
mean I don't see anybody else getting
flowers
that's kind of crazy maybe she felt bad
I did feel like she went she
particularly hard on him when they were
talking about that whole like nurturing
thing yeah and it was like it was
exactly what you had said like people
are allowed to feel a certain way about
a partner and break up with them and not
say it just to not hurt their feelings
like yeah you have to say everything you
feel you don't so and they just like
would not let it go Nick too yeah
um so I mean I don't know if this she
deserves to be fired I don't think she
should be fired but I think that if like
the producers agree that she went too
hard then she can pull it back next
season but I feel like she did what she
was asked to do she was she did the job
she was hired to do yeah and I feel like
they wanted to have hosts who would be
as passionate as the viewers feel and
really feel like they're representing
the viewers it didn't work out and the
viewers are like even though I think the
viewers agreed with some of these biases
it's so painful to watch her like Badger
people yeah even I thought what was more
painful was like the conversation about
babies yes she's better she's gotten a
lot of flack for that and I I understand
like you know just asking the general
question like babies you know you just
got married it's not like crazy crazy
and it's not so offensive but she's just
like would and stuff like she literally
wants a date no it was like she was
trying to reach like a word limit on an
essay like she just kept or like they
needed to hit a certain amount of time
on the like she wouldn't let it go no
and like as a viewer I'm like these
people just got married let's talk to
season one couples about having a baby
at least like right if we're gonna if we
need love is blind babies right now
speaking of season one couples a lot of
people and I actually don't disagree
with this say that you know they hate
Nick and Men I said they want to replace
them with Lauren and Cameron Hamilton
which
um honestly it's probably a good idea I
just don't think that Nicki Vanessa
deserve to be fired I don't think they
deserve to be fired I love Lauren and
Cam I have not seen anything that would
show me that they're good hosts right I
feel like we always have this
conversation where just like everyone
thinks that oh I like this person they
should be a host and it's it's it's his
job for a reason
um I think what is Vanessa Lachey's
resume she was like a TRL yeah she was a
host yeah and is a host
um and I think just she'll edit herself
a little more next season if that's what
the producers want from her but I do
feel like at the end of the day even
though the reunion wasn't t-filled the
season wasn't like amazing there's only
so many questions to ask I don't feel
like there was any question that she
didn't ask that I want an answer and
there were so many questions that she
did ask that I was like yes you're right
yes and she were like even when she was
grilling Marshall she remembered every
single important thing that Jackie said
in the interview yeah and got act we got
information from him all in all it was
just like a very weird reunion and I
think a lot of people are like blaming
everything on Nick and Vanessa and like
yeah they definitely could have done
better
um but the live element made it so weird
there were some many audio issues we
didn't even talk about that when
someone's mic was on in the control room
who was that I don't know it was so
[__] weird and then like threw
everyone off who had to forget who was
talking at the time I think it was Paul
Marshall whatever yeah but then there
was like a few other times when someone
else's mic was like popping there was
quite literally no reason for this
reunion to be live
um and I think a lot of the issues
people had with Nick and Vanessa would
have been
um
eliminated had it just been edited
because nobody really has ever had a
problem with them prior
and the reunion itself was just like for
cocked for a multitude of reasons
including Nick and Vanessa being weird
but to blame it all on them is just like
it ain't right yeah it should not have
been live but I do think that even her
her passion would have come through and
edited yes version but I think that's
why people have liked her up until this
point like she's very invested in the
internet yeah she's invested like she
actually cares I don't know if it's fake
or whatever but like it's nice it's nice
and We complain all the time like it
doesn't seem like Andy cares and here we
have two people who are like she was
referencing all these things from the
internet that I never even heard I'm
like oh wow I really feel like up to
speed Andy actually went on radio Andy
and like spoke about this
um just the element about it being a
live reunion and how like they should
have learned from Real Housewives of
Miami like live reunions are the most
unnecessary thing Beyond unnecessary
it's not like Netflix is like known for
their live programming so what this is
like the second thing they've tried to
do why this I don't know it must be
enormously popular like beyond what we
hadn't even expected yeah because Andy
say why Real Housewives of Miami was
such a flop like on his from his POV
because it was live it was psychotic
like what element of it uh no he just
said it was chaos and they've never done
it again yeah and it was bad yeah even
though it was bad in the moment but now
we look back on it like as like a
historic iconic moment but yes I guess
when we watched it at first we were like
this is crazy I wish we got a regular
Reunion yeah but now in like the Bravo
Hall of Fame for a show that like you
know went on Hiatus and it's just it's
kind of like a it's a badge of honor to
have been a part of it I actually think
if this love is buying should not have
been live and the technical piece was
the worst part and like the fact that
everyone was waiting
but as far as the content that came out
of it aside from the long-winded answers
from some people that needed chopping
down I actually felt like the content
was fine like they moved along yeah yeah
they asked every question everyone got
to speak oh I also did read because you
and I watched the live stream we were
able to but most people were not okay
and most people got it up on their
Netflix the next day and I had heard
that pieces of it were cut like it
wasn't exactly what we you and I saw I
mean they should have cut out I'm sure
they did you know when that Mike went
rogue in the control room so any
technical stuff but I don't know what
else will that make sense kind of like
how Chris Rock he like flubbed a joke to
joke and they edited it for when it
stayed did they yeah they they fixed it
right oh okay good yeah I think about
that a lot how [__] annoyed he must
have been at that moment I know if you
didn't watch his special it was good you
should go watch it I mean he has this
like big joke at the end about the will
smithing he doesn't talk about the Will
Smith thing until the end and everyone's
just kind of like waiting waiting
waiting and then he [__] pops off
it's like 20 minutes he's mad but he has
one like really technical joke that that
is it's like a three minute joke so he
plants something in the beginning of the
joke and then by the end he brings back
something like a call back to something
you spoke about three minutes ago it was
supposed to be very brilliant
um and he totally [__] it up and he
was like so visibly mad at himself and
then he did it again he was like let me
do that again and did it again so I
think when you watch the edited version
it just cuts to as it should yeah I'm
sure they said that to him like if you
mess up just do it again and let it
doing a live comedy special I mean I
don't know I guess it's like not that
different than just doing like a live
comedy show yeah but like it is crazy
but a live comedy show people can't
watch over and over again like it's a
moment in time it's crazy it was really
cool again like unnecessary yeah I don't
know why Netflix is getting into the
live game
I don't know it's like all these
streamers are now becoming just like
cable I'm dropping three episodes at a
time no and then they all like merge
and they're just channels everyone is
doing this dropping like New Seasons a
couple episodes Miss maisel only has
three yeah so now they need to make
money are we gonna have to start
watching commercials like it's literally
becoming television no you're so right I
was actually thinking like during the
Love is Blind thing if they were gonna
have like a sponsor or something like
this love is blind is brought to you by
or just product placing like everybody
drinking Dasani or something yeah yeah
that's a good point and we're like
moving backwards I know and it's like
Netflix is giving us less and less these
days not dropping binge Seasons doing
fakata live and their subscription price
keeps going up and they're you know
stopping all these things you can't
share passwords more than one person on
a household becoming cable it's becoming
cable
yeah the cable location of Netflix of
streamers of streamers yeah because I
mean peacock I literally watched with
commercials peacock is cable but at
least it's because it's cable it's NBC's
you know what I mean but like I pay for
Less commercials did you also use your
HBO Max is rebranding to Max to
Maximilian which wouldn't be a bad name
but HBO is like a legacy brand whole box
office like and I'm like good with HBO
Max I didn't feel the need to edit I
feel like they don't need a Rebrand
they're in a really good place right now
they're still straddling like the line
of cable like they do episodes once a
week but it doesn't bother people
because they're HBO yeah it's like
there's a precedent I don't know why
they're trying to fix something that
ain't [__] broke not at all I
don't get it not at all and it's going
to be confusing are we watching Max
tonight I don't know when my babysitting
literally it's gonna be confusing and it
used to be confusing because remember
they had HBO GO HBO HBO Max they had
like four different things HBO Go and
then they got their [__] together and
it's like HBO Max okay we are HBO Max
HBO Max now you're gonna switch it up
you're finally doing well like you're an
actual competitor a lot of people
thought you wouldn't be like stop yeah
everybody's just doing the most but like
the least but I hope that if they do
Rebrand like again in a few years as you
know companies do that they would brand
to Maximilian
I think it's a little long no but it's
like a really powerful name for a
streamer
what does Hulu stand for Hulu like HBO
is home box office Netflix is internet
flicks movies yeah flicks from the net
right what the hell is Hulu I'm looking
it up Hulu meaning oh I'm not typing
anything and what are the other
streamers a prime I guess that just like
doesn't mean anything it's just the name
Hulu comes from two Mandarin Chinese
characters
Hulu which is Calabash bottle gourd and
Hulu interactive recording oh it comes
from a Chinese proverb Hulu is Mandarin
for gourd g-o-u-r-d okay
uh and and gourd in ancient times was
hollowed out and used to hold precious
things oh you know they just have like a
branding agency coming up with a bunch
of names and they said we want to be a
verb like Google
Hulu and it's because we hold precious
things or interactive recording or
interactive recording I mean it works it
works it works and it's a good amount of
letters h-u-l-u like but it's a stretch
major it holds many things what other
streaming oh Disney plus Paramount plus
now that's like the trend everyone doing
Discovery plus yeah yeah I'm sure
eventually those will Rebrand yeah
there's so many now I know I feel like
we're forgetting one really big one I
know
Netflix
Hulu HBO Max Prime I said Prime oh and
it's just like that's an extension of an
already billion dollar brand like it
doesn't yeah but it's called Prime video
they gotta drop the video I actually
like the the logo like the square on
your Apple TV it just says Prime oh
really yeah
yeah that's good I could see them
changing that yeah
um okay well wishing uh Nick of Vanessa
like a good idea I know I'm not into all
this backlash also people really
underestimate like how difficult it is
to host something like that and I
thought they did fine and they I'm I
think that they did the job they were
hired to do and and next year there will
be edits based on the 6 000 people right
the successful it was really fine
um before you continue let me just let
you know that today's episode is brought
to you by Skylight frames you know Jax
and I live in far apart very sadly and
it can be a struggle to stay connected
but after I got her a skylight frame and
I sent her photos almost every day
um it brings us both so much joy it is a
special way for us to stay connected so
if you have a family member or a loved
one that you don't live near check out
the Skylight digital photo frame it is a
sweet and meaningful gift that will give
you a new way to stay in touch with
those you love it's so simple and fun to
use even if you're not tech savvy
there's no app or subscription required
to send photos anytime you can do it
from anywhere so anyone in the family
can send photos to the frame it is a
great way way to keep family members
connected it sets up effortlessly under
one minute and even the least tech savvy
person can use it it looks like a real
photo frame that adds a beautiful touch
to your home Skylight frame has a
gorgeous 10 inch or 15 inch touchscreen
you can swipe through photos with your
finger and even tap the heart button
letting the sender know that you'd love
to the photo it makes the frame
interactive and fun to use it holds
thousands of photos that continuously
rotate throughout the day and they bring
daily Joy it has 100 satisfaction
guaranteed so if you don't love your
Skylight that'll offer you a full refund
also Mother's Day is coming up so if you
want to purchase one you can pre-load it
with your favorite photos for a special
Mother's Day gift and then surprise your
mom with photos that they didn't even
know you had
everyone loves the Skylight frame One
customer even said we gifted this to
both sides of our grandparents and they
haven't stopped talking about how much
they enjoyed it now as a special
Mother's Day offer get 10 off which is
up to 30 off your frame when you go to
skylightframe.com toast that's 10 off
which is
up to 30 off your purchase of a skylight
frame when you go to skylightframe.com
toast that's
s-k-y-l-i-g-h-t-f-r-a-m-e.com slash
toast today's episode is also brought to
you
by primally pure if you want to have
your healthiest year yet and become the
most vibrant version of yourself start
here by cleaning up your skin care
products swapping for natural options is
a must if you want to feel good and glow
from the inside out and primarily pure
has harnessed the power of natural
ingredients in your complete line of
non-toxic beauty products from Skin Body
baby hair and More You Can't Forget
Their cult favorite natural deodorant
primarily pure products are handcrafted
with real raw ingredients to optimize
your results and your overall health the
testimonials that flood their Instagram
feed inbox and website are proof that
pure ingredients really do create
positive change in your skin you won't
believe the before and after photos and
the transformation stories from their
Community across the world from
handcrafting natural skin care creating
educational content and cultivating
intentional community and even offering
organic facials at their holistic spa
primarily pure exists to help Empower
you to only improve your skin but lead a
healthier more fulfilling life so if
you're on the fence about making the
swap to non-toxic products especially
natural deodorant check out their five
star reviews at primally pure com from
customers just like us natural deodorant
is very touch and go but I have to say
primally pure has so many good reviews
and when I tried it it was doing the
damn I have it in my purse right now
I've been using it I like the lavender
one it's really it smells nice and and
not like those other natural deodorants
once you're convinced use code toast for
15 off your primary per purchase
purchase that's
www.p-r-i-m-a-l-l-y-p-u-r-e.com slash
toast use code toast at checkout for 15
off your order that's primallypure.com
toast code toast for 15 off your order
thank you you know that's a great segue
into our next story all natural
deodorant natural rally all the way to
on that trial armpits because Rachel
McAdams okay I saw this photo of her and
I was like oh she's hairy armpits and
then it looked like maybe her hair
um on her head was just like because you
had like a wind in her hair was blowing
like the back of her ponytail into her
armpit I was like oh she doesn't have
very but she does she does and that's
just like a small part of this story
because she is sat down for an interview
with bustle she has a new movie coming
out she plays the mom in Judy blooms are
you there God it's me Margaret yes and
she's talking about her career about
taking breaks from acting she took a
two-year break recently saying I needed
to stay sane she talks about some of the
roles that she's turned down along the
way because like she just was on a break
was on a break but also no like even
after Mean Girls like she turned down
Devil Wears Prada Casino Royale Iron Man
um and she also is posing with her
armpit hair so but not but she she
talked about like the that she didn't
want the publication she it was with
bustle she didn't want them to retouch
the photos a lot but like she didn't
like really talk about the decision she
just had her armpits there was like no
explanation yeah she said this my body
that's totally fine about like a million
things you know post but having kids
like this is me yeah
um okay so let's quickly talk about the
fact that she could have been Andy in
Devil Wears product because I really
could see it would have been Andy yeah
who else I don't know Emily Blunt no she
was so in no and I saw the article the
that said it was the and half that would
have been a great Andy she would have
brought that morning glory energy nerdy
like chaotic so a lot of antic
celebrities will be like well years
later say oh I was actually initially
offered this role and I can't really see
them in that role but this is one of the
few times where I actually really could
have seen her
in this film yeah she said she was also
she also turned down Iron Man whatever
Iron Man gets smart Mission Impossible
three and Casino Royale that's a Bond
movie I guess like the big ones are like
Devil Wears pride and Casino Royale like
that sucks and Iron Man
um but I have a lot of respect for her
taking these breaks and like no matter
what opportunity came across like
sticking with the fact that she's on a
break I think that's like so healthy and
it kind of makes sense because she's so
normal to me yeah
um and like the movies that she has
chosen to do since then like the
notebook like she stopped like chosen
winners yeah
I mean I wouldn't say that Eurovision
one was a winner but it's a morning
glory yeah no she's she's a star and she
can afford to pass up on things like
this because hey it doesn't seem like
she really cares about being in every
film and having the most money and the
most accolades like she just wants to
live to work not work to live you can't
dance at everything no sorry work to
live not live to work you can't dance at
every wedding right and she seems really
balanced and I love that for her so I
don't think it bothers her that she
missed out on no she seems like a a star
with a good head on her shoulders she
takes being a mom really seriously and
her career really she's a very serious
actress and a very talented actress and
the movie looks really cute but it is so
cute I only recently heard that they
were making are you there got it to me
Margaret into a movie I don't really
remember what that book was about I know
it was about a young girl going through
changes yeah like puberty cute
cute cute I'm sure the film will be cute
Judy Bloom is a p Jam
um
but let's talk about the armpits yeah
let's talk about them because they're
just there I think they're you know this
is me these are my armpits you know she
could have shaved for the shoot and she
didn't no and you know what I put her
arms to her side but she didn't so I am
like vehemently against having hairy
armpits personally I don't care what
other people do with their bodies but
like for me I just know like I will
never be the girl who has hairy armpits
and shows them off yeah of course
sometimes I grow out but it's private
right right and I got them lasered like
there's literally only so much they can
grow it's not a statement
um but I don't care what other people do
with their bodies and I just hate when
people like do things and it's like
women should do that like shut up women
should do whatever they want so if her
she's out here with her armpits like not
even like saying anything about it like
I love that yeah I just hate when people
like do things and they're like oh women
should do this like shut up or like
shaving armpits is bad it's for the
patriarchy you know what it's not like I
just want to shave my armpits okay like
is that okay right
like I just hate when they when when
people do things in articles like this
and I have to make like a big statement
on it she didn't even mention it I love
that yeah
so Rachel McAdam she's back in the game
so oh she's promoting Judy Bloom okay
that's like a cute role for her yeah
what was the last thing she was in it's
not like no I think that Eurovision
movie sorry there was something in 2020
it was
so she just came off a break is that
what she was saying yeah got it that
makes sense because I feel like
sometimes she's like popping and then
sometimes I like forget about her
yeah and she credits Mean Girls as like
her breakout role she wasn't in anything
before that not
of that caliber it is so crazy the
trajectory of the Mean Girls when you
look at someone like Rachel McAdams and
then you look at someone like Lacey
Chabert like how were they both like
they really had the same launching pad
yeah but look at Amanda Seyfried right
exactly Rachel McAdams it's just about
what's it about like who your team is
team
desire desire perhaps
it's crazy what you know life right who
do you think's the most successful post
Mean Girls of the four
Amanda Seyfried
Rachel McAdams I think Amanda Seyfried
it depends on what the Yeah it also
depends on the year like I like Rachel
McAdams movies better than Amanda
Seyfried it's like I didn't watch the
drop out I didn't watch Mamma Mia maybe
there but
in terms of success I'm not saying who
would we like most I'm saying who's most
successful
like for every one movie of ones there's
a there's like a equal of the other do
you know what I mean no because
because Amanda Seyfried has a franchise
Mamma Mia does Rachel McAdams have a
franchise she's in something I think big
transformers I don't think she's in any
Marvel she's in Transformers no I'm
saying I don't think she is I think
she's in one thing like that like a
marvely DC Comics Vibe yeah like a
money-making machine
okay let's see we're on her IMDb Dr
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness oh
okay that's definitely that's like
something yeah Eurovision game night
Doctor Strange again Spotlight True
Detective boom
drop drop a comment who do you think is
more of a success let's pit women
against each other Rachel McAdams or
Amanda Seyfried Sherlock Holmes
two Sherlock Holmes is
the hot chick oh my God the throwback
that was after Mean Girls yeah yeah
iconic so good that movie was really
good just here to remind you Rob
Schneider's daughter is Elle King yeah
Wedding Crashers oh yeah like there's
really good and those are movies that I
love and I think Amanda Seyfried has
like you know Letters to Juliet or
whatever but I didn't see it right so I
I say personal preference like I think
their net worth she has Letters to
Juliet and she also is Dear John right
she has two movies about letters she
writes a lot of letters she's constantly
writing letters let's see don't touch
the Morgan ladders
Amanda Seyfried imdb oh she was in Les
Mis yeah she's very oscarey yeah
Rachel's not she's more commercial yeah
that's true it's very Kelsey and Juliet
commercial versus editorial yeah
that's another reference like I don't
think I'll ever stop bringing up like
when they were talking on Siesta Key
about like being a commercial model
versus an editorial model but it was
Kelsey verse herself it was Julia wasn't
involved
like Amanda Seyfried has so many movies
and I have never heard of that right so
I guess maybe like Rachel McAdams is
more your Niche but I'm just curious who
people think Ted two of course but to me
that's like a travesty yeah because it
should have been Mila Kunis yeah
Dear John
okay
there's a lot there's way more movies
for me to see if we just want to say
more volume because she didn't take
those years off um
comes full circle
are you ready for our next story I don't
think you're ready for this jelly and
get ready for this jelly I think we're
all ready for this next story because
Victoria Justice is addressing long time
rumor that she's jealous of Ariana
Grande
shout out Aaron Lim for asking the
questions that like needed to be asked
Coachella right yeah they interviewed
her at Coachella they posted the
Instagram on Monday
um and she said that despite not wanting
to talk about this topic anymore she did
she said we were both like this is so
stupid she said of hearing the Rivalry
rumors for the first time more than 10
years ago uh justice now said Ariana
texted her at the time and they both
blasted The Narrative that was creative
of them created of them not being
friends with each other yeah she
basically said this is like an internet
thing me and Ariana are fine I've spoken
to Ariana multiple times like I wish
people would let this go and I can't let
this go I can't let this go and I think
we all shouldn't let it go and I'm sure
that
it's fine I'm sure that like I don't
think I think Victoria was looking at
her Instagram after this I think she's
like very happy in her life in her
career and you know isn't like with her
voodoo doll of Ariana and it doesn't
really like think about Ariana you know
because they both come it's been 10
years yeah um but I do think at the time
that we all realized that there was
something going on no I think there's an
element of truth to this in the sense
that back in the day when they were
literally tweens and like they were all
popping off and it was definitely
competitive and those child show
environments were like toxic there was
an element of jealousy I think that's
like human nature
um
because you know it was Victoria's show
but I think like everyone like in the
cast like loved Ari so much and already
had this amazing voice and it was a show
about singers and like for some reason
Victoria Justice was the main character
but like Ariana was this Powerhouse
vocalist like there was definitely
something there and I'm sure they all
moved on I'm sure they're fine now yeah
but I don't know there's just weird you
know Ariana's like really good friends
with Liz Gillies and Matt Bennett from
the show and they like come to all of
they've come to see Ariana on tour and
they've done like projects together and
you know Victoria and Ariana haven't
done any projects together so I'm just
saying yeah like I don't think it's out
of nowhere I think maybe it wasn't as
big as people made it people made it
probably wasn't like the only thing
happening on set maybe it was just like
a small undercurring yeah
and I think just the way we've all sort
of hung on to it is because like we're
immature and petulant children because
of the video
yeah if we all hadn't seen that I don't
think that we all would still be talking
about this that video interview of them
as kids goes viral every six months and
it reaches an entirely new audience
which is why people don't let this go
because people are like every day
somebody new learns about that video and
I feel bad for Victoria that it just
kind of her whole life is whittled down
to this one interview I think she could
have responded and been like I think we
all know that's not true yeah no once
again it's like once you lean in it
it'll pass you by I think she thought
she was leaning in by responding to it
and like you know finally addressing it
no but she said in the interview she's
like I like don't want to talk about
this like she made it seem like there
was more there like maybe I'm done
looking into it too much no and I I want
to like believe her you know because
people deserve to be believed 100. but I
think we all know about your video we
all know the truth
it's like I actually feel bad for her
but like not enough to stop
agreed it's like if I
if I like put this to bed could I still
say we all
no because that's you not putting it to
bed right so I can't so I don't think we
all can put it to bed
we all stay awake yep
but I do feel bad not enough to stop not
enough to stop because it's like so much
it's just a part of who we are now it's
our DNA to say I think we all should uh
like
I think we're all it's also I don't even
remember what the original line is she
said I think we all sing yeah because
there was like an interview question
um who's the most musical Elizabeth Liz
Gillies was gushing about Ari singing
how she just like will burst into song
in the middle of a conversation and it
wasn't even a question like and then
they were like to Daniela Monet but
Daniela also does that and then Ari and
Liz were like yeah Daniela and then out
of nowhere Victoria I think we all sing
it's the best moment of my life like I
will never stop talking about it sorry
and to me
it just it seems so silly it's harmless
and harmless but I do feel like
it's not to her yeah
but it's also and this is going to be
like I guess mean maybe we're all still
talking about it when it comes to
Victoria Justice because what else is
there to talk about like she needs to
get out there do more projects for a
while she was she and we're sent Nina
jailbreak I get them so confused that
holiday movie me and Dobrev okay so for
sure they influencer Victoria Justice
well she needs some more things because
we're just talking about this because
she's given us nothing else to talk
about like she needs like a scandal or
something I don't know
yeah no I just think
we all sing
I think the same I would agree
anyways it was glad to see her looking
well yeah she looked cute like in her
element as an influencer Coachella yeah
are you ready for our fifth and final
story yeah
real houses Beverly Hills Alum Teddy
melon clam Mellencamp claims that she
had a one night stand with Matt Damon I
totally believe this by the way yep so
Tamara is outing some of BFF Teddy
Mellencamp's sex life Secrets the two
peas in a pod co-hosts appeared on Jeff
Lewis live on Tuesday where Tamara
forced Teddy to open up about her
one-night stand with Matt Damon 20 years
ago Tamara said she mentioned it on a
podcast and then went back and told
producers take that guy's name out and
so now I tell people if you guys want to
know just DM and I'll tell you who it is
that's funny she tells people on the DMS
I'm like stop telling people Teddy said
I did not want to out this guy who knows
um I mean 20 years ago Matt Damon was so
unbelievably hot like I'm so happy for
Teddy I definitely believe I feel like a
lot of times
Real Housewives
like say that they like remember Carol
bradswell said did she slept with George
Clooney she did or she went on a date
with him something like that
um every now and then like a celeb like
certain Housewives who really are
believe like I believe Teddy Mellencamp
was running in circles as like a young
nepo baby with Matt Damon 20 years ago
Carol radzwell was like very much in the
upper echelon I could see how she would
run into George Clooney
um and I find this fascinating and I
love that she's sharing yeah it's really
funny
Teddy and Tamara are such unlikely best
friends best friends they have a really
successful podcasts I know you know
Teddy Mellencamp's post Housewives life
could have been really sad
um but it's not I feel like Kyle really
keeps her in the fold like so she's
still very much like films a little bit
and I do I have heard rumors that she's
filming this season
um I feel like she totally should
because she's there anyway like
sometimes you have to work so hard to
invite someone to these events but like
with someone who's always around
um and has something to say like I feel
like that's fine yeah she really should
bring her dad around more like as much
as um duree brings around Boy George
like we should be seeing John Cougar
Mellencamp because John Cougar
Mellencamp is like I mean Boy George is
like obviously like major but like
jungkooker melon Camp is like especially
for the people who watch Housewives
which is like mostly older women yeah
they're like it's like he's like their
King yeah so I feel like she was booted
off a little too soon I know people
really didn't like her at the time but I
feel like she's had a really good post
Housewives career her podcast is
extremely successful it's actually
really impressive like her and and
Tamara like work really hard at it they
spill a lot of tea anything even
remotely Housewives related that's like
a tiny bit of tea they say for their
podcast it's really impressive yeah I'm
happy for her and like honestly she
should come back
she should come back but also remember
back in the day we used to say she would
have been better suited for OC yes
that's what people used to say because
she did have a house in the OC too but I
do think I know she wound up BFF with
Tamara I know but I think like their
relationship only works because they're
on different franchises like I don't
think it would be as you know copacetic
yeah had they been on the same show and
I guess that's probably part of the
success of their podcast is that they're
on different franchises because I think
a lot of Housewives have podcasts with
Co from their franchise but I think that
they are one of the biggest housewife
podcasts and they're not even active
Housewives no well Tamara currently is
she's on osino she's it's airing no but
it's filming okay so yes I but when they
started they were both kind of like
defunct yeah and this podcast has really
turned it around for them it's like it's
an amazing it's amazing what a podcast
could do it's amazing what a podcast can
do and the cream Rises don't forget that
don't forget that and don't forget the
teddy melon Camp had a one night stand
with yeah I'm like I love that for her
yeah Matt Damon was um in air have you
haven't seen it no you really should and
he was excellent in it look at my uh but
like 20 years ago Jackie that's a
Goodwill Hunting like that was when he
was like maybe I was like Goodwill
Hunting was like a little bit older than
that but that was like when he was
really really hot yeah he's still
handsome but you know his prime it's
just a fun fact I love that for her I
bet she has like other crazy stories
about like being John Mellencamp's
daughter like that's iconic yeah
she ever really spoke about it I think
she was like very afraid of being like
known just for that and everyone be like
all right we get it like stop talking
about your dad so she ran away from me
to the point where I literally forget
that she has a famous father yeah until
she posts about him on Instagram I'm
like oh yeah that's like a fun fact
about her but I do wish she would talk
about it more I bet she has like some
wild stories maybe she talks about it on
her podcast maybe another incentive it
would be a good place to talk about
things another incentive for everybody
to listen all right well those were the
Fast Five you certainly needed to know
them but don't fret because the show is
far from over because we've got to your
toasters our weekly advice segment where
we give advice to anyone who needs it on
anything that they might possibly need
help on so the email if you want to
write in is deertoesters gmail.com we
check it weekly so make sure you're
writing in if you haven't heard from us
yet either we haven't seen it or your
submission stunk or it was too long so
maybe tighten it up and resend it in and
if we've written in if you've written in
recently and we've helped you like hello
write us an update we haven't gotten any
updates from these you know ungrateful
wrenches who just take our smarts and
run damn they're blooming where they're
planted Club I know it's actually good
if they're you know were so many updates
it would be like more Tamil and if it
was bad they would come seeking out our
help maybe it's like we give them such
good advice they're just happy all right
that's true well dear toasters we're
gonna dive into it's brought to you by
Topgolf it's golf it's not golf it's
Topgolf we have a bunch of stuff at
Topgolf that makes them golf they've got
clubs the balls the t's the turf the
ball picker upper thing they also have a
bunch of stuff that's not golf like
great music giant Targets in the Fairway
TVs handcrafted food and beverage menus
they have a whole day each week
dedicated to more play or less play so
they do this thing on Tuesday where all
gameplay is half price giving players
more reason to just come play around
so we've been to Topgolf in Nashville
we're actually going back again next
month it was so much fun we went for a
girls night and obviously none of us are
like big golfies but we had the best
time playing we knew we would have fun
with like the music and the food and the
drinks but the way we all got like crazy
competitive you actually want is that
correct I did and I love when we do
these ads because I can remind everyone
that I won at Topgolf she did win at
Topgolf but we had so much more fun
playing the golf than we even expected
and now when we're going back we're
doing like a couples trip with a lot of
the boyfriends and husbands coming so we
were like what should we do the night
before we're going to Taylor Swift
concert and somebody suggested Top Golf
and it's like it's perfect the boys will
love it we loved it and it's what I
really like about it is it's like
Outdoors but kind of in their base which
is like where you sit and post up with
your drinks before you play they're
heated in the winter and cold in the
summer and we went in the summer last
time we were dying but it was so
temperature regulated it was fabulous I
was wearing long sleeves
um
so if you want to check out Topgolf they
have tons of different locations it is
fabulous if you love golf it's golf it's
not golf it's Topgolf food and beverage
is great everything is great it's just
great for a night out girls night
couples night date night whatever
today's episode is also brought to you
by a brand new a sponsor that I'm really
excited about because I wore their
sweater on the toast last week with
Paige because I needed something like
fabulous and I got so many comments
about it so shopping for clothes is a
compromise it often feels like we have
to choose between saving up for an
expensive luxury piece or settling for a
cheap fast fashion item that won't last
well we have elevated our closet with
Quince with Quince we get high quality
Timeless pieces without paying the
luxury price tag they offer a range of
must-have items but like real Staples
that you need in your closet you can
wear multiple times a week
um so they have like 100 Mongolian
cashmere sweaters for fifty dollars they
have 100 European linen pants for forty
dollars luxurious Mulberry silk skirts
at sixty dollars all their prices are 50
to 80 percent less than luxury Brands
and that's because Quince creates
Timeless classic styles that won't go
out of fashion so you'll have them in
your closet forever I actually got a
pair of black slacks from Quince that
are probably the most flattering pair of
black slacks and something I could wear
every day it's like a closet staple so
it's like you're you're investing in
good pieces but their prices are really
reasonable
um that cashmere sweater I wore with
Paige where she said I looked like a
rich older woman giving Rich Coastal
grandmother that was also from Quince I
love everything I got I also got like a
really cute cropped white cardigan they
have really cute stylish pieces but
mostly like classic pieces that you can
just have forever
Quinn's Partners directly with top
factories so they cut the cost of the
middle and middleman and they pass the
savings on to you they only work with
factories that use safe ethical and
responsible manufacturing practices and
premium eco-friendly fabrics and
finishes so we feel good about getting
high quality items that are lasting
longer I would never have known about
Quince if they didn't sponsor the show
and I'm so glad because I have I think
maybe three or four pieces and I'm
definitely gonna get more
um and again they're all things that you
can just wear I'm like so self-conscious
about wearing things too much but
they're just like basic staple items
like it doesn't matter where I wore that
cashmere sweater with linen pant but
like I can also wear it a bunch of
different ways and No One's Gonna know
yeah so Shopkins today and discover the
affordable luxury you deserve right now
go to quince.com toast to get free
shipping and 365 day returns on your
next order that's Quince q u i n c e.com
slash toast for free shipping 365 day
returns quince.com toast Quinn's not
like the Disney Channel original movie
Quince yes all right are you ready for
deer toasters to change some lives I'm
ready what do you got for us okay
hi Jackson McLaren love you guys long
time toaster here and log and MSG I was
there I'm 24 years old single New York
City gal and I've been trying to
prioritize dating I've gone on so many
dates and I'm constantly bored by these
men a bunch of big fat nothing Burgers I
tend to be extremely picky with guys and
I find an excuse to stop seeing them
after a few dates but I've been seeing
this new guy for a few months and he has
literally no icks he's so hot he's smart
he's interesting we're culturally
similar I mean very similar values we
have a really strong connection but
there's one thing
he self-published three books and I read
them I sort of ignored how
self-publishing is a little cringy and I
read them anyway he keeps asking me for
my thoughts in a super genuine and
bashful way and I don't know what to say
because the books are insufferable I've
just been thinking about I've just been
giving vague compliments but thank God
this is not his day job because it
really feels like I'm reading some
random kids high school English paper
that never ends this feels so mean to
say because he's such an amazing guy and
I really like him aside from this I
don't want to lie to him but I obviously
can't say I hate your books I don't know
if this is a real issue or just me being
dramatic and looking for an out it's
making me want to end things which feels
so crazy help what do I say to him and
do I keep seeing him love a well-read
toaster I just want to say I only find
fault in one thing that you said and
that's that self-publishing is cringy I
just want to say self-publishing is
probably the smartest thing you can do
financially and it shows initiative like
obviously he's not like a writer with a
huge following like you can't just get
published and the fact that he's not
like waiting for some you know a
hopeless dream to come true he just took
initiative I feel like it actually show
owes a lot of really good qualities you
want in like a partner also I imagine
that that's not his full-time job she
said it's not so this is a hobby I think
it's really important for people to have
hobbies like creative Outlets just
things that bring them joy and he's
taking initiative getting it published
like not you know waiting and hoping
that this book is going to be like the
next big thing
um but moving on with his life while
also pursuing his passions it is really
awkward to like read someone's book and
not like it and there's three of them
and he wants to know what you think
um but I think we can chalk it up to
just like this awkward thing about the
relationship if everything else is so
perfect like do not do not things do not
like that's hella dramatic I don't know
I think it's sweet like
I think it's cool when people have
passions I think it's cool I mean you
have to be somewhat financially stable
to self-publish because you got to put
up a lot of money so like maybe he's
Rich we love that I'm just trying to
look for the positives in what ways is
the book bad like is it what kind of
book is it what kind of book is it like
is it a memoir because it's just like
you know it sounds like Paul talking on
Love Is Mine like it's just like verbose
and goes on because that's like okay not
for me right is it you know written in
layman's terms and it's just really
terrible like is it
what's the genre you know I feel like if
it's a bad Thriller okay like whatever
if it's bad you know self-help space
[Music]
yeah if it's bad smut I honestly I don't
find anything wrong with this just like
you're in an uncomfortable situation
because you didn't like the books so
like how do you move forward just lie I
like this is a lie that doesn't hurt
anybody yeah you could
because of this genre but I thought it
was so good I think it's so cool that
like you're right right and that you
took the time to write those books I
don't it makes me like think more of
this guy the fact that he's like
obviously very like well read and
intellectual he to create something like
put something pen to paper that's
extremely difficult it's while also
maintaining that this is not your
full-time job and having another career
and he wanted something and he went out
and got it I feel like it shows like
perseverance you know and I think
quality is there they're good qualities
in a partner like for the Long Haul I
agree completely you don't want someone
who's boring like you want someone who's
curious and like has I don't know things
to say and is well read and you'll never
be bored yeah and knows how to like busy
himself like writing books and
self-publishing like it's important to
have healthy Hobbies like that oh and
you never know maybe it wasn't for you
maybe the book goes viral on Tick Tock
and it becomes the next great writer
maybe one day your kids like make a
Tick-Tock video about my dad wrote this
book 14 years ago and it flopped so hard
on it please like go read it and then he
becomes a New York Times bestseller love
um I don't think there's anything wrong
I think you're looking for problems
maybe like like I think you and you
admitted yourself like you're very picky
and you're like looking for a way out or
Nick and that's definitely what's going
on here yeah it's definitely like a this
is Uncharted Territory okay I would say
you could classify this as an ick but I
don't think one ick should break a
relationship no and an ick is like an
unreasonable thing in someone that you
find icky it's not any ever a legit
that's a whole concept of an ick it's
like oh my God I get the egg when he
like stands up yeah so what he shouldn't
stand from someone once does that mean
that you should break up like what does
an ick really mean no I think culture
has gotten out of control like I think
it's it's spiraled a lot now to the
people where people are like looking for
IX because it's like funny and it's just
like you know oh that gave me like when
he did that
but okay yeah no it culture has spiraled
out of control to the point where like
everyone's single because they're
getting icked out by like oh my God he
breathed I can't believe Zach and I did
a podcast episode together a few months
ago on patreon
um one of the questions was like what is
something that the other does that gives
you the Egg and I actually had like the
perfect response and it's like we should
still be married but when he does this I
get the it what was it it
using the word Binky instead of pacifier
agreed oh great Jail jail jail to the
man
that's disgusting
it oh
more problem equals solved right all
right next up hey Jackson Clarin how you
doing
obviously unexpectedly got let go from
my job I've always been so career driven
and I feel so out of place and really
lost I now have to be my boyfriend's
extended family and I can't help up
feeling like a bum and I'm like
embarrassed I met his parents and
brother already and I know that he
already told them which is mortifying
can you help me navigate how I answer
questions about my work as his extended
family will certainly ask I feel so
awkward answering questions and I just
want to cancel all together please help
PS don't ever stop singing okay do not
cancel we'll help you navigate like that
part of the conversation but I think
what you should focus on is just being
like an impressive wonderful girly for
the rest of the night like you are there
so many ways to impress and just like
showcase yourself outside of whatever
your job is like your job is just your
job and right now it's you're in a lull
but that doesn't mean they're going to
write you off completely like no so get
your story straight about like what's
going on with your job so that you sound
like someone who who wants to work and
you're not right you're not a bum even
though you feel that way right now but
then like
charm them you know what I mean like be
interesting be knowledgeable be have
opinions uh be up to date on what's
going on like that will just be like oh
she's in between jobs right now but
she's an amazing girl no and I also
think context around
um like the current economic crisis is
really important like you weren't just
let go like everyone is let go like what
was it Google laying off 12 of the
Facebook Netflix everyone is being
everyone you're first of all you're not
alone so that should make you feel
better and two like why don't you just
go into Iran about how like the current
government is just like not working and
like you just get political you know
like oh can you believe I don't even
track I don't even know like what the
right word is but like oh people to
judge you know like something like this
[__] Global crisis I don't know
whatever like talk about that because
like you were you were let go you said
you're career driven you were like oh
cause you're a bad employee you're like
oh cause nobody can afford to keep
people hiring anymore because the
economy is so bad so it's like going to
that be like oh I wish I knew like the
right thing to say oh inflation you know
something yeah yeah but also it's like
you know what's a really good example of
this like I feel like love is blind when
Zach met bliss's Dad it's like because
he is a lawyer like that's so impressive
and he like made that his whole
personality and to the point where it
wasn't impressive yeah and it's like
okay so you have a great job but like
the rest of the conversation is trash
flip it like I'd rather have a great
conversation with someone who's like in
between jobs right now and just like
doing their best but the rest of the
meeting of the parents is going great
right it's so important to remember like
you are so much more than your job like
and jobs are so fluid and people come
and go and fire and quit you'll get
another job I don't think they'll be
overly concerned like I think you just
gotta like take it on the chin you know
and like instead of don't be embarrassed
don't be embarrassed don't be like uh I
feel like sometimes be like well I'm I'm
working on some project like don't lie
yeah just be like I was doing this for
this many years at this company I was
like so passionate about it this is what
I want to be doing with my career they
made Cuts so I'm not in that role
anymore but I've applied to here here
and here and I'm really um optimistic
yeah have like a full answer so they
just move on from the question and then
you can talk about literally anything
else and then in everything else dazzle
dazzle Razzle Dazzle which you should do
anyway yeah even if you had a great job
like you're not just gonna sit on your
laurels you want to Dazzle your
potential new in-laws I also feel like
when it comes to a job in like hetero
relationships with like meeting parents
it's always like what does the husband
do because it's like a husband's
supposed to provide for their wife or
whatever
um so maybe you'll just get lucky and
his parents are very traditional they're
like oh good she doesn't work more time
in the kitchen
and then you offer like a blueberry pie
recipe or something oh yeah yeah bring
good food drinks like Dazzle that's what
Dazzle sparkle and shine yeah
women of New York Frost yourselves
all right our third and final deer
toasters hey Jackson turdy Lou I'm a gen
Z toaster who found you guys through
Tick Tock clips and I listen every
single day you are seriously getting me
through college so I'll get straight to
it you're okay do you want to take a
minute just to pack yourself no it's
good I'm so used to this it happens all
the time
there's this guy I've been hanging out
with for a while now I'll go over to his
apartment we watch shows we have food
Etc I also regularly spend the night and
he's the one who asked me to stay over
so I don't feel like I'm overstepping or
anything the thing is this guy is not
going to move he wants me around and I
can tell he obviously enjoys spending
time with me he seriously is a pee Jam
he's also super shy it took me a while
to even get him to get to see more a
more open side of him when we were just
hanging out when we go to sleep he gives
me my space and we genuinely just sleep
he only kissed me once and it was when
we first met and he was drunk but after
that he's just comfortable hanging out
and just talking without any intimacy
don't get me wrong it's not awkward at
all we still have an amazing time but
how do I break the cycle of like being
in this weird friend zone yeah thank you
guys it's like he didn't friend zone you
but you are his friend yeah friendship
this litter is a book I just read and it
was because the guy's like so extremely
socially awkward to the point of like
like anxiety and he's like really smart
and funny but like only when you really
get to know him and she's like so
excited to get to know him and every
time she does she like Falls more in
love with him it's actually not a good
book but it applies here
um it sounds good it sounds like he's
just really shy yeah maybe and like he's
getting so comfortable with you to the
point where like he will be 100 of
himself at some point and the more time
you spend even though if you're like a
really shy person like sleeping with
someone platonically he's like psychotic
yeah but it sounds like he's getting
comfortable and if you really like him
and you're having a good time and he's
having a good time this is all really
nice I feel like if you want things to
progress that you might have to
let him know that you're ready for that
like he might need a green light from
you I'm not saying that you need to like
pursue it and be the one who like goes
in off every single time no but in the
beginning for sure in the beginning for
sure maybe like I don't know what you
guys do when you like order food and
watch TV like maybe get a couple drying
stuff in there yeah nothing like crazy
because you don't want to like rely on
it you don't want to rely on it and also
you don't want to like do something that
would be so different from what you
normally do but like a spritz or two
yeah just get them feeling a little
loose yeah it would help you will have
to take charge in the beginning but I
think there's something really cute
about chai guys there's like always like
another layer like you're just
constantly learning more about them yeah
I think you could like make it like a
cute little kiss move and then turn it
into a conversation and then it's like
you're really one of the only people
like you and like his family who really
know him and like he doesn't give like
other he gives other versions of himself
to other people but you know the real
him it's kind of like crazy he's like
worth waiting for him like worth being
patient for yeah but you're just gonna
have to do like a little more leg work
than you might have in a different
situation but a different situation like
when a gardener use such a pee job oh my
God like I'm kind of obsessed with shy
guys like now that we're talking about
hey shy shy shy shy he's shy it's so
cute like I like to be good he'll be shy
when he goes out to the club yeah no
he's not gonna be like out here at strip
clubs because he's literally too shy
he's so shy I love him please keep us
updated yeah just like make little moves
make a move you have to be comfortable
knowing like in the beginning like
you're gonna have to be the one who is a
little bit more aggressive but it's fine
the ball's in your court he obviously
likes you he has you to sleep over yeah
if you were a friend quote like an
actual friend and he only saw you as a
friend he would invite you to hang out
and stuff he would not ask you to sleep
over yeah like maybe like in bed like
you like grab a hand you're like put
your foot up your hands yeah that's a
cute way to sleep yeah just do something
yeah baby steps yeah
but I think it's worth pursuing it
sounds really promising I'm excited I
feel like this is the start of a
beautiful song none of this ever happens
in college no I know it sounds actually
he sounds so like Advanced and evolved
yeah I'm like obsessed with this guy
obsessed I need a picture honestly
please update us just like anything that
happens don't let him go don't let him
go no I'm telling you like he's the one
maybe I'm like romanticizing it because
I just read this like romantic book but
like I'm he's the one for you like the
picture I have in my head is just like
so sweet and I don't see anything like
nefarious or
like that no red flags here no no no I'm
obsessed
that was your toasters our weekly advice
segments if you ever want to write in
it's deertoesters gmail.com thank you to
everyone who spoke with us thank you to
everyone who listened to this episode we
love you dearly don't forget to hump
someone you love today
and we'll see you tomorrow thank you so
much for listening to the toast and
Monday Morning Show where we deliver the
fast five stories you need to know
everybody through Friday on YouTube so
you're watching this on YouTube please
subscribe this video thumbs up we're
also available at Spotify
we'll see you tomorrow and before
tomorrow's episode drops merch will be
available at toastmarch.com 10 A.M
eastern time set your alarms and gird
your loins love ya bye